du warst es mich für was du hast lotter
das foto untergeschoben auf dem du und
ich uns geküsst haben
du musst zugeben dass du dich nicht ganz
korrekt verhalten hast
wie bitte ich wusste doch noch gar nicht
dass leute mit ihm zusammen ist du musst
jeden besser über die informieren mit
denen du dich herum treibst stimmt genau
einem betrüger anscheinend das loch ich
habe die ganze zeit geglaubt dass es mag
war dabei warst du es ja die sachen
gestohlen hat um macht die schuld zu
geben
vielleicht als auch riesen reservoirs
der im holunder das geld aus meinem
portemonnaie genommen hat du stellst
nicht als die band um den verdacht auf
markt zu lenken
warum machst du das alles eigentlich
macht es dir spaß das leben anderer
leute zu zerstören
das macht mir spaß dir hinterher zu
laufen und um aufmerksamkeit zu betteln
so
klaus aber auch der du willst du blöde
kuh
bitte lasst uns in ruhe darüber
schlappe
du wolltest doch nicht dass ich dir
helfen die tür auf lass mich rein
so macht die tür auf
so kleine
die tür auf
so